- I also heard you're
a talented cartoonist.
So, you love doing, how do you,
how do you decide what you're gonna do?
- I do cartoons, it's catharsis, you know.
I've been through a lot of crazy feelings
in the last few years.
So I've been doing that.
And I let it take me
where it wants to take me.
And I do painting, and I do cartoons.
- That's so cool.
(audience claps)
- Yeah I love it.
- I've tried painting, I'm not good.
- Yeah, it's so cathartic.
it's so wonderful,
and a year later it tells you
what you wanted it to say.
- [Kelly] Like crazy.
- [Jim] Okay so this,
this is the story of
the prodigal son to me.
That's my father
and that is basically
every day of my life.
When I take the shell
off (audience laughs)
and I'm born again every morning.
- Oh my god!
- Yeah, so I did that one
on Easter and I just said,
"Hey, let's shake off all this, you know,
vitriol and whatever it is
and become united again, and let's -
- That's such a healthy thing though,
like using that as your vehicle.
- Yeah, but the prodigal son one,
I don't know if you can put that back up,
it's quite weird-
- [Kelly] Dark?
- No, it's not dark actually.
- [Kelly] No, not at all!
- [Jim] It looks dark and yet
what it represents from me
is a lot of people don't
think about these stories,
you know, the prodigal son,
the two siblings that, you know,
one goes off and gallops,
gallivants around,
and the other one stays in the kingdom
and keeps it running, right,
until the prodigal son comes back.
Well, the prodigal son is your mind,
at any one moment
you're either in your body
or you're not in your body,
and your mind is the prodigal
son or the prodigal daughter,
- You're either present or not present.
- It goes, the heart can't go anywhere.
It has to run the body.
It has to keep the blood pumping.
And so it's stuck,
but the mind can go
anywhere it wants to go.
- [Kelly] Which I love.
- And sometimes that's fantastic,
except when it takes you over,
and it prevents you from doing this.
It prevents you from doing this.
And all of the things and the
walk in the morning and stuff.
So, sometimes when you're in,
can I say, "Hell on earth"?
- You can, and I have been there.
- Sometimes when you
are, that's time travel.
You can never really, it's
very difficult to be unhappy,
if you're really in your body,
if you bring your brain back to your body,
and sometimes that's what pain is.
Pain is your body
calling you back, saying,
"I'm your heart and I miss you."
- [Kelly] Yeah, work on this!
- Come back, come back.
- That's so cool! (audience claps)
I thought you meant
the black and white one
of your father, that's the one I,
I was like, "Looks a little dark,"
but it's great.
- That was my dad.
My dad is, that was I did from
a photograph of my father,
in his early life,
standing on a rooftop in
Toronto with his pet rat.
(audience laughs)
- Wow.
- My dad was one of the
most incredible characters
that you ever met in your life,
the funniest man that
ever walked the earth,
and he makes me look
like, I don't know what.
Like a Shakespearian tragedy.
- No but you should know this about you,
like you have a really cool
vibe and light about you,
and you're so welcoming,
like I've only been on this
show for like five months,
but like a lot of times you meet people
and they all have walls up,
and they're so afraid
and they're so serious,
'cause they want to be taken seriously,
and it's like, it's really refreshing,
so thank you for being
such a light, it's cool.
(audience cheers and claps)